simplify to a squared over three B to
the fifth all of that to the fourth
power so here we can use the property
that if I have x over Y and I'm raising
that to the nth power this is the same
thing as X to the nth power over Y to
the nth power and we could see that with
an example real fast if I had let's add
X over Y x over Y to the third power
what would this be equal to this would
be x over Y times x over Y times X over
Y which is going to be equal to x times
X times X over Y times y times y and
this is clearly X to the third over Y to
the third so I just gave you a
particular example of why this works
hopefully it gives you enough confidence
or it makes you feel good about using
this property so let's use it right here
in our actual problem so we have 2a
squared over three B to the fifth all of
that to the fourth power so this is
going to be the same thing as 2a squared
to the fourth power so let me write it
this way it's going to be 2a squared to
the fourth power let me the fourth power
in blue to the fourth power all of that
over three B to the fifth all of that
over 3b to the fifth to the fourth power
to the fourth power and now we can use a
property that if I take the product of
things and raise that to a power that's
the same thing as each of the day of
raising each of the things in the
product to the power and then taking
their product so this is going to be the
same thing let me just write the
property here so if I have if I have x x
times y to the nth power this is the
same thing as X to the nth times y to
the nth power and you could do a similar
argument that we did right here to see
why this works out so let's do that over
here 2a squared to the fourth power is
going to be equal to 2 to the fourth
power colour-coded 2 to the fourth power
times a squared to the fourth power
a squared to the fourth power and then
all of that over three B to the fifth to
the fourth power that's going to be
three to the fourth power
three to the fourth power times B to the
fifth times B to the fifth to the fourth
power times B to the fifth to the fourth
power now the last interesting thing
here and we can evaluate what these
numbers come out to be two to the fourth
power let me just do it right now two to
the fourth - 2 squared is 4 2 to the
third power is 8 2 to the fourth power
is 16 so this right here is 16 3 to the
first power is 3 3 squared is 9 3 to the
third power is 27 3 to the fourth power
is 81 so this over here this over here
is let me do it in that green color this
is 81 81 and to simplify these terms
here we just have to remember the I
guess we call it the power property or
the power rule of exponents and that's
just the notion that if I have if I've X
X to the N and then I raise that to the
M power this is the exact same thing as
X to the N times M power so if we wanted
to simplify this our numerator is now it
is now 16 that's the 2 to the fourth and
then a squared and then that to the
fourth power that's going to be a to the
2 times 4 power or a to the 8th power
this is literally 2 times 4 so we're
just multiplying 2 times 4 this 2 times
this 4 to get that 8 and then in the
denominator we have our 81 and then B to
the fifth and then that to the fourth
power that's going to be B to the 5
times 4 power or B to the 20th power so
I got 20 by multiplying 5 times 4 and
we're done this is about as simplified
as we can get